my name is Mike sergeant
the filmmaker and a film critic been a
film critic for about 15 years but I've
been a filmmaker for about 20 years I've
been writing screenplays for about 20
years and the script that I'm writing or
rewriting actually is a script called
the decoy decoys a script that kind of
evolved out of the script I wrote for my
first film the script was featured a
woman who was the sort of the love
interest of the main character and I
gave her a really interesting job and
through the course of getting that film
made and it's the only feature film I've
actually made a lot of the backstory of
this character got cut out cut out of
the script got cut out of the film but I
loved what she did it's a very
interesting job a decoy is a job where
you actually work for a detective
company and or detective agency and what
you do is let's say a woman thinks her
husband or her boyfriend or fiance he's
going to cheat on her or is cheating on
her what she does is she hires a woman
who goes someplace where she knows the
guy will be and she pretends to be you
know single and chats him up and of
course the whoever the woman is it's
picked this decoy pick some woman that
she knows that her intended or her
significant other would go for and of
course this woman is wearing a wire or
as a secret video and kind of catches
him in the act and there it is the
relationship can be over again when I
couldn't put this into the screenplay
that I wrote I love the job and I built
a whole story around it and I kind of
created a sort of a Hitchcock type story
where she has this job she goes on an
assignment and gets caught up in
something and everybody's after her and
I wrote this script because that's the
kind of film that my first film was a
romantic comedy but I'm a big Hitchcock
political thriller sci fi kind of guy
and this was the kind of script that I
love I love Hitchcock I love the whole
you know person in the wrong place at
the wrong time wrong time type of film
and the interesting thing that happened
is when I wrote this which I wrote
around 2000
shortly after I wrote my first or made
my first film I had put it about five
six years in the future and in this
future I had envisioned that oil prices
said prices had gone through the roof
and that you know there was all kinds of
natural disasters going on and the
economy was in fluctuation and it was
all the backdrop for this story but then
what happened in four or five years in
the film didn't get made all this came
true so I had to update the story to
really make it it's supposed to be sort
of near future science fiction so I'd
had a couple of predictions that were
integral to this story but it you'd know
that it wasn't today but this is what
could happen so I updated the script
around 2010 2011 and I updated and I
created some more things having to do
with natural disasters and other
elements political going on and then all
of that happened so finally ah after a
number of things now that i'm going back
to filmmaking because I stopped being a
filmmaker really to be a single dad and
now that my daughter is in college going
back to filmmaking and going back to
this project and a few other things and
I've updated it again I've made a few
years in the future and let's just hope
that the things that I predict will
happen won't happen this time and I can
get to make the film before that they do
they come true one lesson that screen
writing has taught me is that writing is
rewriting that no matter how good your
first draft is it's just a first draft
you just got to keep working on it keep
working on a keep working on it I
remember hearing screenwriters talk
about how they had written 30 40 drafts
and I was like oh my god that's insane
maybe all right two or three but now
that I'm working on you know what would
probably be 12 13 14 3 aft of the
screenplay for a number of reasons i get
it and i get each time it's like a
sculpture gets home down more and more
and more and you can say more with less
and less is more especially in the
screenplay when i go with this
screenplay is to have it you know like
many filmmakers one
this is a film that I want to make I
want to get made uh I want to attach
myself as director but I really would
like to get talked out of being a
director so that I can actually probably
get paid a little more but get a
producer's credit so that I could work
with a more established filmmaker to
learn more about the filmmaking process
I made my first film and very proud of
it but of course there's always a lot
more to learn I'd like to learn more on
a film that I've written and then be
able to direct the next script that I
really want to direct where I could
really show more of my visual style and
how I would really like to tell stories
if I had the opportunity my
screenwriting goals are that i would
like to both write direct produce for
the rest of my life i have all kinds of
stories that i want to tell all kinds of
stories I love science fiction I love
comedy too though that's not necessarily
what i want to do but I love science
fiction specifically because I feel the
relationship between science fiction and
comedy is that in a science fiction or
comedy you can tell stories about the
human condition that in other genres
would be heavy-handed whether it's a
jean a drama or something like that my
first script that I wrote was a big
budget science fiction epic that was you
know based on a character I'd had since
childhood in and it went pretty far i
got interest from agents and i had
meetings and things like that but I
learned very quickly that people wanted
to buy the story but I would have
absolutely no power they take it and do
whatever they want so I wrote my first
film or the very next script that I
wrote which became my first film to
write something that I could make I
never thought that I would get the money
that I did get to make to make it but I
did and it was because it was a somewhat
contained story that a good screenplay
is like a stage play where it's not
about the locations and everything it's
about the characters and if you care
enough about the characters you'll stay
with them you'll stay interested and you
can tell a really good story that's
something i learned that was very
powerful very helpful for me
the screenwriter so i right pretty much
in the mornings when i first get up and
then i'm a really a late night person I
love writing late at night can't always
do that during the week when i'm working
but weekends weekends are for writing